what's going on guys welcome to part
three of machine learning and pattern
recognition for use with stock in forex
trading where we left off and we're just
wrapping up our data there's a few ugly
parts to the data so we're gonna fix
those things and then one more thing I'm
going to show you is just another
representation of that spread because
again I feel guilty because I'm pretty
sure we're gonna leave spread out of
this entire series so just want to point
you out or point out spread to you
before we end up going down this really
really long path that probably won't
ever get back to spreads so anyway let's
go ahead and do some stuff with this
plot and then we'll be on our way so the
first thing that we did really only
change we made to just the raw plot
right was I mean we I guess we changed
the figure size and then we you know we
did the dates but we haven't really done
anything else so there's a couple other
things that we probably ought to do and
just for displaying this kind of this
tick data the first thing that we're
gonna want to do is once we've arranged
this date the next thing that I think
that we ought to do is what we can we
can do is kind of curve or angle the
date so we can go for label and 8 X 1
dot x axis got get on Explorer tick
labels empty parameters and then just do
label dot sit underscore rotation and
we're going to set that to 45 degrees
next thing that we really want to do is
fix member on the y-axis how it was like
I don't know the numbers right it was
doing like a plus 1 point whatever we
kind of want that to go away except that
just looks ugly there's no reason before
what we kind of want to see these
decimals so because it does that for us
for for a good reason right so most of
the time you don't really care about
like really long decimals but in this
case this is one of those times where we
do care so what we're gonna do is do
plot GCA and the dot get underscore
y-axes empty parameters again get
underscore major minor school formatter
and parameters stunt dot sit underscore
use offset and then we just want to turn
that to false so it doesn't do that to
us so now let's just see where we are
real quick and make sure we didn't do
anything wrong or typo it's highly
likely that I type Oaks it's hard to
type and talk and sure enough I did I
put a comma right here so you'd dot if
you were actually following me make sure
you put that dot there and I get this
stupid air I did that now let's try
again see if we've got any other errors
yeah we didn't okay so here's what we
got right now obviously the dates kind
of thing go out there but again this is
really just one day where the data so
doesn't matter too much plus if you see
down in the bottom right where you cover
you can see the time and the value so
it's not a huge deal
but I'll show you guys how to fix that
just in case you care yeah so anyway we
close out of that that's looking good
for now let me hit this gonna give me an
error okay so to make space for the
bottom what we can do is use this
subplots adjust so you plot that's uh or
yes sub Lots underscore adjust and
become one of my justice the bottom and
we want to add point two three again
that's another thing that's covered
pretty well in that other video so it's
pretty much all of this stuff so if you
want to know more about formatting
charts you can check that out but again
that's not really the focus of this
tutorial let's I've already covered it
so I don't want to you know cover the
same stuff especially for the people who
have already watched those other videos
now the last thing I really want to do
is show you guys a representation of
that spread and so if you did watch the
other video it'll be a lot like how we
did volume right so what we're gonna do
is we're gonna say ax one underscore two
so like second version Avast one that's
just gonna be ax one got twin X empty
parameters and then all we want to do is
do a s1 underscore two dot fill
underscore between and what do I want to
fill between both date first then zero
that's like the minimum that it will
fill under and then
ask - bid so this is basically ask - bid
obviously it's gonna be the ask price -
the bid price otherwise known as the
spread so ask - bid and then we'll just
give it a face color of like green and
an alpha of 0.4 and that should be it we
show a pretty decent looking chart at
this point so let's say that we'll run
it and put in girl obviously if you're
not totally new to Python to run the
function you gotta type in you know
graph it fast enter and here is our
chart now so we can actually see
everything it's got that freaking offset
I know it's I know what I did wrong what
we need to do is move this plot GCA
offset really want to offset the a x1
plot stuff so put that here and then it
really will offset that so let's run it
one more time alt p and there we go much
more pretty okay so anyways now you can
actually see you know the this this down
here is the spread size basically so you
can see some cool stuff with that spread
size but anyway just something I wanted
to show you guys since we did have bid
bid ask tick data here that you can do
with that data so anyway we're going to
close out of this those out of this so
anyways that's going to conclude the
third video in the machine learning for
Forex and stock trading in the next
video we're going to start building up
our pattern finder so we're going to go
through the text file and start looking
for patterns as always thanks for
watching and thanks for your support of
subscriptions and until next time